my name is maniac Peru I'm a nurse from
the inaudible health center in community
I've been working here for as long as
I've been a nurse I grew up in great
well which is also known as poop
dropping I'm 59 years old old old old
what made you decide to go to school to
become a nurse
um it's a weird and long story there
there was a nurse who came from Great
Britain in England her name was Miss
Leslie
Murray she was there for probably 20
years and we got close and when the
federal government started sending
students to Churchill Manitoba she
wanted me to go so she got the Anglican
Minister behind her because my parents
didn't want to let me go she finally
said I'll pay you $25 a month to let me
go to Churchill and my mother let me go
for $25 I tried to go into nursing as
soon as I finished my high school grades
and people I should say white people
were not ready for that for for me so I
quit nursing school when I had only six
months to go and I I didn't heal from it
for 20 years and I went back after 20
years
what was it about nursing that attracted
you at such a young age helping helping
my own people
miss luckily made me start Mather will
start moving around in there
I saw her helping a lot of people and
that really attracted me like she helped
my mother because my mother could never
have children that stayed alive I have
three brothers and three sisters and
they all died and I saw the nurse really
helping her were there other nurses
Inuit nurses in your community when you
were growing up no no this the first
time I went to school was the first year
there was a school in great well so
there were no ingrid nurses at all there
were no nobody with any profession do
you talked about that when you first
went to nursing school that white people
weren't ready for you
so was it a bad experience at that time
you don't know how bad and probably
nobody will ever know how bad it was
what was it that finally made you go
back and and get your schooling finish
it and and becoming her 16 years ago um
we had been living in Yellowknife
there's no nursing schools there and
when we moved to Timmins I realized
there was a nursing school there and I
kept applying for RN and they kept
rejecting me but I kept applying every
fall September finally when I applied
for RNA they took me in and I
transferred to the registered nurse
class later what was the nursing school
experience for you like the second time
around nearly the same nearly the same
but this time I was much more grown-up
much more mature and harder in my heart
so you were able to push through
everything I think I was sick
in class when we graduated I was
thinking about my other old class
thinking what would they say they saw me
now once you started seeing patients
what was the reaction of the community
of preventive is predominantly Inuit
what was the reaction like when you
walked into a room okay the first one of
the first patients I had he was in a
wheelchair and I came in with my little
cup full of medication and he was
staring at me
like why are you giving me medication
and we don't give me medication the
other nurse the nurses giving me
medication so I explained to him I am a
nurse and then he listened for a while
about my going on about how I am a nurse
then and without saying anything more he
was really garlic we're in charge in
here what's the reaction like now when
you walk into a room I'm hoping they're
proud it took a long time to get used to
it it took a long time for me to get
used to it and for them to get used to
me what do you think are the main
challenges of delivering health care in
the North it's the great distances and
the turnover it's really incredible the
turnover is incredible we're a long way
from somewhere somewhere people perceive
to be important and here in Quebec it's
languages okay everybody doesn't speak
the same language so some of the
messages get really twisted and that can
impact the health of the people who are
the consumers of health care challenges
also
again related to language when I'm
translating all the teaching materials
it's very hard to translate medical
terminology into interested the other
challenge was that because the the in
which they see macro not micro so they
don't understand germs or they don't
understand your blood circulating in
your body it's hard to explain to them
that there's something wrong with their
body with like diabetes and when they
don't feel sick when somebody gets sick
in the South they do bloodwork to see
what is wrong with you and they do an
interview on you and when you're doing
that on an inward person they don't
necessarily understand why are you doing
that they don't necessarily understand
what you're interviewing them there's
some some some of them I think that just
think you're visiting with them so it
it's hard
are the health concerns that people
bring to you are they different now than
they were that when you started from my
point of view related to diabetes there
are babies obesity Rose there's no lack
of food now people don't know which
foods are good choices why people have
food eating schedules like breakfast
lunch and supper and we don't have that
whenever and whenever there's food
available - and does that affect health
even now it is especially for the person
who is pre-diabetic and their body is
struggling to control their blood sugar
and yes very much we've been hearing in
the other Arctic regions as well that
health systems are based on the southern
kaolinite way of doing things and
doesn't take into account Inuit culture
and I'm curious if you've seen this
either as a nurse or someone living and
working in the north it's very
frustrating on both sides because the
nurses are expecting the reaction to be
the same as in the south and it is not
the nurse gets frustrated because the in
rate sometimes does not follow the
nurses instructions because maybe he
didn't understand maybe his culture
doesn't do that or doesn't it's not a
normal thing to do an Indian root
culture but the nurse wants them to do
it so they can be healthy again but
they're working against each other there
needs to be way back down south before
they hire them there needs to be a
cultural
in addition there needs to be someone's
down there saying this is what you're
going to encounter these are the people
and this is from someone who knows what
they're talking about
what do you think needs to be done to
have more nurses actually from the
communities working in the north people
like you trying to get the story out
that we need them teachers and people
who are in charge of education really
pushing pushing pushing it it's it's a
really good experience to be a nurse you
get more than you give you're saving
lives so it's very it's when you see a
person get better it's why you became a
nurse when you see them get better do
you consider yourself a role model no
and I don't want to be really I feel
like I know qualify
you